we've learned in other videos that the
atom is in fact made up of even smaller
constituent particles which is pretty
amazing because Adams already
unimaginably small and those particles
are the protons which have positive
charge you have your neutrons which have
neutral charge or no charge and then you
have your electrons which have negative
charge now the big question physicists
and chemists were facing over a hundred
years ago is how are these things
configured and they realize that the
positive charge is concentrated at the
center of the atom and in fact most of
the mass which is made up of the protons
and the neutrons it's concentrated at
the center and so the early model for
how an atom worked was maybe you have
your protons and neutrons in the center
so let's say we're talking about a
helium atom a helium atom has two
protons in the nucleus and it all and a
typical helium atom would have two
neutrons as well so the nucleus might
look something like that
an early physicists and chemists said
alright well look the protons have a
positive charge electrons have a
negative charge so they'll be attracted
to each other opposite signs opposite
charges attract the same charge repels
each other
so maybe the electron which has a
negative charge orbits around the
nucleus the way that a planet would
orbit around its star so maybe it orbits
something like this so maybe one
electron has an orbit that looks
something like that and then another
electron if you're talking about a
neutral helium atom would have two
electrons and two protons
well maybe the other one or bits
something like this I'm trying to just
draw an elliptic or a circular looking
orbit and so this is the idea that the
electrons are in orbits now turns out
that this is not exactly the case
electrons are not in these well-defined
circular or elliptical orbits in fact at
any given point in time it's not
necessarily exactly right there it could
be there but there's some probability
it's here there's some probability it's
there there's some probability it's
there some probability it's over there
and so to describe where electrons are
likely to be found
physicists and chemists introduced the
idea of an orbital and the best way to
think about orbitals is to think about a
hydrogen atom and actually the math for
orbitals its hydrogen is the simplest
atom and so the math for orbitals has
been best completed for the hydrogen
atom so in the hydrogen atom especially
the typical isotope of hydrogen found on
earth the nucleus actually has no
neutrons you just have a single proton
at the center and if you have a neutral
hydrogen atom that one electron instead
of being in orbit around that one proton
like that we can really just think about
the probabilities of where it might be
it could be here it could be here at any
given moment it could be there at any
given moment it could be off the screen
at some moment but it's more likely to
be in certain regions of space around
the nucleus and others and we can
visualize where it's most likely to be
by saying all right it looks like 90% of
the time it's in a sphere that looks
something like that
but once again it could be here it could
be there could be there could be there
could be there could be out here it
could be anywhere we're just saying
where it happens to be 90% of the time
that's the visualization now an
interesting question is what if you were
to give that electron a little bit more
energy well what does energy mean well
if you think about planets or a rocket
or satellite orbiting around if you were
to give it a little bit more energy if
you were to give it a little bit push it
could have a larger orbit it would look
something like that but quantum
mechanics isn't about things happening
gradually sometimes people think quantum
means small or something like that no it
really means that you're talking about
discrete packets so in quantum physics
quantum chemistry if you add a certain
amount of energy to an electron instead
of being having a 90% chance of being
found in this first shell this first
energy level it could then be found
it would then jump into the next energy
level or the next shell and so now it
might be more 90 percent of the time
it's going to be found in this shell
right over here and then if you were to
give it the right boost of energy once
again just a little bit won't do you
have to give it enough so that it jumps
into the next energy level then it might
form these weird patterns that look kind
of like dumbbells where 90% of the time
it's kind of you can view it as it's on
the orbital that looks kind of like that
dumbbell shape and you could I just did
it in kind of the horizontal direction
you could have in the vertical direction
you could also have it on the in/out
direction of this page and if you're
wondering where do these shapes come
from and if you keep adding more and
more energy you get these more and more
exotic shapes for orbitals think about
standing waves that's my best hint I can
give you that at the quantum level
actually at all levels but especially at
the quantum level you see things like
electrons have both particle and
wave-like properties and so imagine
something like a standing wave where if
I were to just take a rope and if I were
to just shake it I might get standing
waves that look like that if I were to
take a some type of a membrane in two
dimensions and if I were to push on one
side right here if I were to drum on
that you might get it so that this part
dips down and then that part dips up and
so when you get to three dimensions you
end up getting this dumbbell shape when
you add more energy and then you get
more and more and more exotic shapes
just to imagine what some of the first
orbitals look like rendered by a
computer you see it right over here
so if you have your lowest energy
electron you are in what is called an S
orbital right over here and this one we
would call 1s because it is at the first
shell the one closest to the nucleus if
you give even more energy then that
electron might jump into the second
energy level or the second shell and the
orbital in that second shell which would
be the default if it's the lowest energy
in the second shell would be the 2's
orbital once again you have this
spherical orbital it's just a little
it's more likely to be found further out
than when it was just in the one shell
and once again if you add even more
energy
you'll fall you'll still be in the
second shell but you will be into one of
these orbitals that have higher energies
so you could view this as the 2p orbital
that is in the X dimension this could be
the 2p orbital that is in the Y
dimension so some people call that 2px
some people would call that to py this
you could view as the in and out of the
page so you could view that as the Z
dimension so that is 2p Z and the
orbitals keep going there is ad orbital
once you get to the third shell once you
get to the fourth shell there is an F
orbital all we've talked about right now
is in hydrogen if we keep giving more
energy to that one electron what happens
to it what is the shape of the
probabilities of where it might be in
three-dimensional space as you can
imagine if you have two electrons it's
not exactly the same but this is a
pretty good approximation you can
actually put two electrons in this 1s
orbital but after that you could imagine
the electrons are repelling each other
so another electron doesn't want to go
there and so then the third electron
that you add is going to end up in the
2's orbital it's going to be at that
higher energy level and then that can
fit too so you can fit up to 4 electrons
between the 1s and then the 2s and then
the fifth one it's going to have to go
into one of these P orbitals now one
last point is to make sure you
understand the terminology of orbitals
and shells so first of all you have this
idea of shells and sometimes the word
shell will be used interchangeably with
energy level energy levels and so in
this diagram or this visualization right
over here I've depicted the one shell
and then I've also depicted the two
shell so this is a shell right over here
this is another shell now you'll also
hear the term sub shell sub shell or
sometimes people will say sub levels and
that's where they're talking about s or
P or D and eventually F so if I circle
this I'm talking about that first shell
now the first shell only contains
one subshell and that's the one s
subshell and the one s subshell only has
one orbital once again the 1s orbital so
for the first shell the shell the sub
shell in the orbital is all referring to
the same thing but as we get to the
second shell it's a little bit different
if we talk about the sub shells the in
the second shell there's s n P so this
is a sub shell and then this is a
another sub shell right over here
there's actually three orbitals in the P
sub shell so I'll leave you there in the
next video we'll actually look at
various atoms and think about their
electron configurations where do their
electron sit in which of these shells
sub shells and orbitals